well this week in our world of mother
series we are exploring what motherhood
means around the globe from North
America to Europe Africa and now Asia
this morning we're in China where
childcare is truly a family affair 2017
report found grandparents helped raise
children during their pre-kindergarten
years in more than three-quarters of
Chinese families then Tracy spoke to a
couple in Beijing who after the birth of
their son added two more people to their
household so most Americans would
probably dread the idea of living in a
small two-bedroom apartment with their
in-laws but here in China it's not only
common it also seems to be something
that both the grandparents and the
parents actually seemed to enjoy it'll
be a few years before Colin GU can drive
a real car and get around Beijing on his
own so for now a two-and-a-half year old
has his parents and grandparents to
steer him in the right direction
shortly after Colin was born li ping and
goo Cheng Chao moved into their son and
daughter-in-law small two-bedroom
apartment to help raise their new
grandson 90% after the family which I
know have their parents in law together
with them
Abigail Chang has long in unpredictable
hours as an executive assistant at an
automobile company her husband GU Lynn
is an engineer so for most of the
workweek the grandparents are in charge
and cooking all the meals would you be
able to have this kind of job if you
didn't have this help from the
grandparents no way yeah I have to tell
you the no way I have to keep my job
because I can only trust them I can only
trust them my parents or my husband's
parents today are the only person in the
whole world war they can love my sense
so much why were you willing to move in
here and help so much so that one just
down that Li ping says it's the Chinese
tradition we are still quite healthy
after retirement being around the kid
every day brings us joy we have nothing
to complain about
historically multi-generational living
has been seen as the cultural ideal in
China with several generations living
under one roof
today grandparents share almost half of
childcare duties with mothers of two and
three-year-olds it's a big part of why
China has one of the highest rates of
women in the workforce in the world it's
not just about individual choices but
it's about what you do to maximize the
well-being of the whole family
University of Maryland sociology
professor Fenian Chen says that in China
parents often leave their children
behind with grandparents as they move
from the countryside to the major cities
in search of better paying jobs
grandparents providing care for the
grandchildren very much creates that
opportunity for other members of the
family mostly the mothers to engage in
other opportunities Chen was herself
raised by grandparents in China and
later in the United States benefited
from grandparents helping with her own
kids without a doubt I would not have
gotten tenure without the help from my
parents and my parents in-law in America
only about 14% of grandparents provide
significant care to grandkids but Chen
says it is more common among certain
communities black grandmothers the
Hispanic grandparents the asian-american
grandparents often times play a much
more prominent role change says that
even though many new parents in China
expect grandparents to help out she
wanted to take a moment to make sure her
mother-in-law knows how truly grateful
what did you say to her and what did she
say to you I said to her that I
appreciate that they have a lot and we
always know that as a as a Chinese we
don't audio say it aloud she said to me
that yeah I'm also a good
daughter-in-law and yeah
you may be wondering if Abigail's
parents also help out with their son
well they have their hands full they're
actually caring for their parents which
would be Abigail's grandparents so this
intergenerational support network here
in China works both ways in families
Gayle well we love that story Ben Tracy
thank you very much I think it's nice
that the grandparents pitch in the way
that they do but do we want them living
with you i I know Kirby and where we go
no thing No thank you but I it shows you
different cultures do different things
different ways I love this make it heart
well yeah I mean I've been so blessed by
a my in-laws and they yeah his love
their grandparents so much but the
distance is part of what makes the
relationship so wonderful yeah totally
and they are angels on earth I agree
with that too